a pamela se le pidió determinar donde la
función htx tiene un extremo relativo
está su respuesta y observa aquí en este
primer paso toma la derivada de esta
función en el segundo paso está buscando
las soluciones donde la derivada es
igual a 0 y encuentro que pasa en x
igualados por lo tanto este es un punto
crítico es lo que dice en el paso 3 está
diciendo que h tiene un extremo relativo
en x igualados ok es a su conclusión es
correcto el trabajo de pamela si no es
así dónde está su error bien entonces
pausa el vídeo y trabaja por tu cuenta
para ver si pamela está bien en su
ejercicio o si no lo está perfecto
es hora de trabajarlo juntos
así que voy a intentar trabajarlo en
paralelo así que por aquí voy a intentar
tomar la derivada h prima de x ok y
observa es simplemente tomarnos la regla
de la potencia en varias veces así que
esto me va a quedar la derivada de x
kubica es 3x cuadrada ok después tengo
la derivada de menos 6 x cuadrada bueno
menos 6 por 2 es menos 12 menos 12 x
y por último la derivada de 12 x es
simplemente 12 ok y ahora de aquí
podemos factorizar un 3 y me quedaría h
prima de x ok igual a 3 que multiplican
a x cuadrada menos 4x ok más 4 y observa
esto de aquí lo que está dentro del
paréntesis es lo mismo que x menos 2 al
cuadrado es decir que esto es
exactamente igual que 3 que multiplican
a x menos 2 esto elevado al cuadrado por
lo tanto el paso 1 está bien ahora
veamos el paso 2 dicen la solución de
prima de x igual a 0 es x igualados
bueno pues si eso es cierto si tomas 3x
déjame ponerlo aquí h prima d
igual a cero esto implica que tres que
multiplican a x menos 2 al cuadrado esto
tiene que ser igual a 0
esto es cierto si x es igual a 2
por lo tanto hasta aquí vamos bien aquí
tenemos todos los puntos que hacen a h
prima de x igual a cero y todos los
puntos donde h prima de x se iguala 0 a
ghana h prima de x indefinida son puntos
críticos y es justo lo que dicen por lo
tanto el paso 2 también es correcto bien
veamos el paso 3 dice
h tiene un extremo relativo en x
igualados y bueno aquí está siendo un
razonamiento incorrecto ella supone que
dado que la primera derivada es igual a
cero entonces tenemos un extremo
relativo así que veamos si esta
conclusión es correcta cuando tenemos un
extremo relativo nuestra curva se ve más
o menos así donde aquí tenemos una
pendiente de 0 es decir aquí tenemos
nuestro extremo relativo
y antes de ese punto tenemos una
pendiente que es positiva y después de
ese punto tenemos una pendiente que es
negativa así que en este caso tenemos un
punto máximo y también lo podemos ver de
la siguiente manera este sería el otro
caso donde tenemos un extremo relativo
donde observa de nuevo aquí tenemos una
pendiente de 0 y ahora lo que está
pasando es que antes de esta pendiente
de cero tenemos una pendiente que es
negativa y después tenemos una pendiente
que es positiva por lo tanto aquí
tenemos un mínimo pero cuidado hay casos
donde tenemos la primera derivada igual
a cero y no tenemos un extremo relativo
por ejemplo podemos pensar en algo así
una función
que se vea más o menos así donde en este
punto de aquí tengamos una pendiente de
0 observa pero antes de eso tengamos una
pendiente positiva y después de eso
también tengamos una pendiente positiva
de tal forma que no podemos hacer esta
conclusión solo con ver la primera
derivada igual a cero cuidado puedes
decir que en efecto es un punto crítico
pero no es forzoso que tengas un extremo
relativo
puedes tener este caso donde tenemos un
punto de inflexión para dar esta
conclusión tienes que probar qué está
pasando con la derivada antes de ese
punto y después de ese punto para ver
que en efecto está cambiando de signo y
bueno podemos intentarlo así que para
eso qué te parece si hacemos una pequeña
tabla por aquí déjame poner por aquí una
pequeña tabla
voy a tener los valores de x y por aquí
los valores de h
prima de x ok y vamos a fijarnos en
algunos valores sabemos que cuando x es
igual a 2 tenemos que la primera
derivada vale 0 así que lo voy a poner
aquí cuando x vale 2 la primera derivada
vale 0 ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo
que pasa antes de x igualados y después
de x igualados en la primera derivada y
probemos qué es lo que pasa con x igual
a 1 y con x igual a 3 para ver
simplemente qué es lo que pasa en cada
lado después y antes de x igualados
veamos cuando x es igual a 1
me quedaría art 1 - 2 lo cual es menos 1
al cuadrados 1 x 3 es simplemente 3 así
que es positivo y ahora con 3 me
quedarían 3 - 2 es uno al cuadrado es 1
por 3 también me da 3
tenemos un valor que también es positivo
de hecho observa es la situación que
acaba de dibujar donde tenemos una
pendiente que es positiva que es
positiva llega aquí al punto donde es
cero y después sigue siendo positiva
positiva positiva y es justo por ello
que tienes que hacer esta tabla para
saber qué es lo que pasa antes y después
del punto crítico y así identificar los
extremos por esta razón ya podemos decir
que este no es un extremo relativo
porque no es un máximo o un mínimo así
que pamela no llegó al resultado
correcto cometió el error en el paso
número 3 recuerda para llegar a una
conclusión correcta debes hacer la
prueba para ver que en efecto la primera
derivada cambie de signo en ambos lados
del punto crítico hasta la próxima